What happens if an astronaut gets sick or
injured in space?
On the moon, you're over three days away,
or on Mars you could be as much as eight months away.
Not everybody on a crew to Mars is going to be a physician.
You have to be able to operate autonomously.
Dr. George Pantalos and the team at University
of Louisville are working with NASA,
Carnegie Mellon University,
and Baylor College of Medicine
to develop novel ways to perform complicated procedures
in near-zero gravity.
When you're working in weightlessness, it
completely changes how you interact
with your instruments, how you interact with your supplies and equipment, how you interact
with your patient. Whoever is providing the care has to be somehow or another fixed in place,
as does the patient, so that you can interact
with them successfully and safely.
In addition to overcoming the challenges of
weightlessness, the team has to consider the
size, shape, and efficiency of medical tools.
You can only take so much with you given the
thrust capabilities of the launch vehicle,
the power, the volume available for storage
in the spacecraft, and everything.
As we're starting to anticipate using a robot
as a surgical assistant during a spaceflight,
might we need to redesign some of the surgical
tools, both to make them easy for the robot
to identify visually, as well as to pick up
with their fingers, and to then hand it to
the surgeon when the surgeon needs it, or
to manipulate the instrument themselves?
George and his students have brainstormed
and built several answers to the challenge
of space medicine, from fluid containment
to 3D-printing.
When we’re working in weightlessness, especially
when we’re doing new procedures and working
with new materials, and materials that might
be hazardous, we want to make sure
that they don't get out into the rest of the environment.
A glove box is a container that you put an
object in to keep it from getting away, simply put,
or to provide special treatment. We've
had to create a very brand-new glove box that
will fit in the size limitation of the suborbital
spacecraft.
During surgery on the earth, you might have
one instrument to provide suction, you might
have another instrument to provide cautery.
We've created an instrument that combines
all of those things together, so in one instrument
the surgeon, at the push of a button,
can do suction, irrigation, illumination, and
eventually will be able to do cautery.
We've developed a hemispherical dome, that
you can put over the location of where the
surgery is going to take place to contain
surgical fluids. With wound waste recovery,
the idea is to recover all of these fluids
and try to filter it and treat it. The output
from that would be drinkable water, sterile
water, or sterile saline.
Which sounds gross, but could help support
astronauts on long term space missions.
For an exploration space mission, there will
be some kind fabrication module onboard that
can 3D print plastics, polymers, metals, tissue,
electronics, and hybrid materials. Those materials
can be recycled and put back into the source
material storage to 3D-print for some other
tool, or a replacement part that might come
up needed later in the mission.
Once George and his team are ready to test
out their new designs, they’ll travel to
the Johnson Space Center in Houston, where
they’ll test their tools
on the NASA zero-G plane.
The preparation for a test flight with NASA
is pretty intensive, but once you get up in
the air and you actually start to see things
work, that's when things get really exciting
and lots of fun. Working in weightlessness
is such a unique experience,
even though it's challenging, it's also very pleasant.
Though it takes several years for the designs
to be tested and approved by the FDA,
George’s research is paving the way for safer and more
feasible human space travel.
If we can accomplish this kind of medical
care during an exploration space mission,
there is a good chance we could do it, let's
say, on a lunar colony that's been established
for visitors to come and visit the moon.
Now,as it turns out, medical tools and instruments
and monitors that are going to be used in
spaceflight could potentially be very beneficial
to make surgical procedures back on the ground go a lot better.
For more episodes of Science in the Extremes,
check out this one right here.
Don’t forget to subscribe and come back to Seeker for more episodes. Thanks for watching!